did you see the article that said
Bloomberg Romney no the bulwark oh my
god that wouldn't be a disgusting
nightmare for this Wow
no but there's there's a there's a weird
paradox almost of like you look at New
York City uh-huh stop and frisk was a
gun control measure literally stop and
frisk was implemented as gun control and
this is the craziest thing to me because
what it ended up doing is it created
this authoritarian racist policy
targeting literally black youth creating
a cycle of poverty and crime mmm and
this is happening in the blue place
mm-hmm so clean your house clean your
room bucko you know what I mean like why
you're gonna go to the national level
and complain when you don't even clean
up your own city instead another now
Bloomberg's is dumping money to buy it
and they're gonna put this guy in office
a lot of that goes down to people not
understanding what the United States of
America means what does it mean it means
that there are 50 separate entities
separate but equal entities that all
come together to you know vote on a
president vote on things that are
federal matters like military or
something of that regard but people
don't hear the states right they think
United States is just the name Lynden it
doesn't mean anything
so you know when you're trying to
discuss the electoral college or
something of that magnitude and they
don't understand why people in Nebraska
don't want people in California telling
him how to run their so weirdest cow
farms yeah I mean like Chicago has gun
violence problems mm-hmm yeah it's a big
city controlled by Democrats yes that's
your problem your law won't work for
Kansas mm-hmm I don't understand why
they don't get this but I guess it's
just you know they don't know what
myopic they can I almost feel like a lot
of them don't even realize that things
can be done like a lot of the citizens
don't even realize things can be done
really at a state level um now I mean in
the last 10 years they knew but now it's
like everything has to be done on a
federal level I think I think it's also
fair to point out it's the inverse is
true with Republicans or at least maybe
it used to be mm-hmm I had Jack Murphy
on I don't know if you know him well we
mentioned it before but he mentioned
that what made it easy for him to switch
from the Democratic Party to the
Republican Party was that cultural
issues came off the table like pot
legalization and gay marriage yes
so how do you would you I mean
libertarian routine you don't do you
care for the Democrat Republican thing
or what's your there's no viable
third-party right now there's not gonna
be a viable third-party until they get
into the debates and right now that's
going through the motions I don't know
it'll probably make it to the Supreme
Court if it's not already sitting in
their dockets somewhere but that's
actually something that Gary Johnson was
pushing to get into the debates and
that's still rolling as far as I know
through the motions to happen isn't that
wouldn't just split the vote like
libertarians and and there's more
libertarians who would vote for Trump
than the Democrats yes yes there's far
more because Democrats right now are
running far far left and there's no
compromise you know there's there's
nothing I can't I mean even when it
comes to wars I mean I am I am against
war and even when it comes to that the
candidates it's almost like war yeah
it's almost like war became a democratic
platform almost in the oh yeah it's it's
it's such a weird phenomenon over the
only Democrat there's Tulsi and Bernie
are the only ones who who I feel like
would not start a war would they
continue a war well I don't know but I
mean those are the ones that it's it
seems like it's an agenda I've talked
about it I'm not doing it start a war is
interesting I actually think they both
would it just depends on the
circumstances yes that's why I'm not a
regime change I'm sorry yeah and I think
I I just think it's it's it's an issue
of would Tulsi invade a foreign country
to change their government no but if
there was like I don't know Weger
torture camps like in China yeah yeah
maybe I mean I don't know I'm probably
not but also I think Tulsi wouldn't is
less likely to start a war because she's
staunchly opposed to it principled and
tough yes and Bernie wouldn't because
he'd be too scared enfeeble I know I
just made up a bunch of Bernie Sanders
supporters angry but I'm not having it
anymore the dude can't even stop a small
woman from taking a microphone from him
yep so look I can riff I can I can
respect his insurgency campaign gonna
come but going up against the Democratic
establishment but that small woman grab
the mic and he couldn't stop her it's
like Trump with a punched her in the
face you're kidding he wouldn't have but
yeah he just shoved her off you didn't
like I may have had his
his secret service there well you know I
mean that's true I don't think anybody
would have even made it to that close to
someone yeah yeah yeah someone rushed
him no I'm sorry trump has Trump ever
has yes yeah okay I didn't see that and
Trump's reaction was he's he spun around
really fast and I don't know if you can
like a lot of people on the left are
like haha he was scared and I'm like he
was alert you could you're clearly gonna
see what you want to see like Trump
supporters are gonna see a president it
was tough and alert and immediately like
yeah started to see what was happening
the left is gonna claim when I'm coward
ya know I you know but but but it's kind
of not fair I mean Bernie doesn't have
Secret Service I think Trump would have
just pushed her I think you you know
yeah does Bernie have security that's
the crazy thing I don't think he does I
mean I've seen you know pictures of him
from people are like haha look you have
guns you know like with people walking
with him yet I didn't see any there
that's that's that's the one thing it's
always bothering his wife walked him
offstage
that's how does he not have security do
they're not vet these people like his
woman ripped their shirts off and they
don't because it's all it's you can't
discriminate you know like you know what
man Bernie's got a real problem with the
people he surrounds himself with he does
yeah I think he takes in a lot of the
people the socially outcasted which you
know that happens and that's fine and
that's great but at some point you got
to have boundaries and he doesn't seem
interesting your play you every played
World of Warcraft I know what happened I
have mm-hmm but it reminds me of the
Horde it's like this ragtag bunch that
don't really agree on anything
uh-huh and they're like all of the
outcasts forming their own coalition
against the Alliance which is like very
you know the Alliance is the big
glorious cities and kind of like in
every Disney movie where all the animals
team up to kill the bad guy I mean kind
of but I don't know a lot of people a
lot of a lot of people listening
probably don't get the reference to
Warcraft but basically Bernie Sanders
campaign is a bunch of people who
probably would not get along in a room
together
mm-hm and they're just basically like
yeah we're Noah for Bernie and they all
kind of
sign their own beliefs - whatever as
campaign is because you've got the far
left that want to burn it all down then
you've got the hippy dippy progressive
types who are like Medicare for all
mm-hmm and I don't know the various
in-betweens yeah as well as some
disenfranchised probably more moderate
Democrat types who hate the
establishment hate Hillary Clinton hate
the machine the problem is you know cuz
I was a big fan of burning the last
cycle but he's like been flip-flopping
hard and about and he's lost a bunch of
people because of it yeah and then you
you know you look at Trump and
everyone's unified under whatever it is
he says yeah yeah and at some point it's
like well that's good that they have
that sort of unification behind one
person at the other it's like you always
want to make sure it's okay to question
anybody if they need to be questioned
you know like it's you don't have to
swear allegiance to a president and
that's that's okay and it's okay to
question him and it's so it's okay to
ask
solutely would you vote for Trump did
you vote for John no I didn't vote for
Trump are you gonna mmm I don't know if
I'm even registered to vote this year
would you would I well I usually do
something obnoxious like all right in
Ron Paul that tends to be what I do I
live in Massachusetts so I'm not even
sure if my state could could even have
the potential to ever flip I could
pretty Mike I wrote and Tom Brady wants
for something I just I don't take voting
seriously there because it is a
democratic stronghold but yeah I don't
know if I was really like mad and I was
going in there I could write him in I
could write him in for everything on the
ticket that's too real yeah just a
really it was gonna be just check it off
I can write him in to I could do
whatever I want cuz it's just doesn't
matter what do you think about the media
criticism that his say he's a
authoritarian he's a dictator he's not a
dictator if we had a dictator we'd know
right so why is he why did CNN try and
persuade me into believing that he was a
dictator what brian Stelter say he said
it's not that you have a dictator you
don't but that there are shades they
were certainly shades of dictator that's
right Trump you know he fired a guy who
worked for him oh you're kidding me no
I'm telling you the truth that you you
guys didn't know this did you actually
me actually
a couple people 70 people who worked for
him oh my god yeah so so he so let me
get this I'm sorry I wait I'm sorry some
of them were reassigned oh they're still
getting paid by the government all right
so so he's their boss and they're there
because he wants them there well they
were there cuz someone else hired him
because somebody else hired so so
they're there to his pleasure either way
yeah and then he fires them right so he
fires the the people that he's the boss
of that are their first pleasure right
so what you're saying is he is a
dictator a total yes that's I've never
heard anything more dictator esc' in my
in my life but as you what you're a big
Ron Paul fan then I'm around Paul fan
Ron Paul's cool dude mm-hmm
when I was younger I was I was really
you know a fan I'm still a fan of Ron
Paul yeah and I wasn't because I
disagree with a lot of the stuff but his
whole shtick was like the government has
too much power and I'm like I don't care
look I'll put it this way
if I was forced to choose between any of
the quadrants and the political compass
yeah he bought the right-wing
libertarian is the best to choose from
you know why why because you can have
any one of those systems within that
mm-hm
the overarching government is like free
market libertarian or anarcho-capitalist
yeah you can actually build your hippie
dippie commune inside that system
absolutely and secure yourself and be
free so if you have if you have a
government that is even lefty
libertarian which is where I kind of
fall which is the hippie dippie living
on a farm with your buddies making you
know growing your own crops and stuff
even if you did that you tell the whole
government where they want you to
cooperate so it's not a Thor terian you
will still have majority representation
or some kind of laws being passed you
might not personally agree with in a
right-wing libertarian state you can go
make your farm and make your kommune and
say leave me alone yes now the other all
the other quads you like the top ones
that's that's anybody's out of the
question
yes they all like you or put you in a
chamber of some sort they'll require
some level of government to enforce your
your utopia essentially right-wing
libertarian you know in the in the
quadrant doesn't want that and that's
what I liked with when it came to Ron
Paul cos what man
10:12 was gonna 12 he yeah 2008 there's
a Ron Paul sticker on a light post on
the street I thought it was funny yeah
Ron Paul 2012 I find it I'm gonna take a
selfie with it
but basically what I saw with his
campaign was if he believes and agrees
with things that I don't yep but his
whole thing is I can't tell you what to
do yeah I'm like hey I'll vote for the
guy who's not gonna tell me what's in
simple I know and I saw we were actually
talking within my libertarian page about
how he was getting at how tulsi gabbard
was getting the ron paul treatment yep
because he will shut out he was silenced
they they did not want they don't war as
profitable and everybody anybody who was
against war is gonna hurt them wasn't
there like the the US army or whatever
said we don't need any more tanks and
then Congress was like well you're
getting them anyway and then signed the
purchase order to like Lockheed Martin
or whatever they're like we're spending
that money yep keeps the keeps it
subsidized the economy I guess to a
certain degree yeah it does I mean it's
dirty money but it it subsidizes the
economy yay government yeah I think
we're gonna come to a point with war
where it's just like robots on the
battlefield fighting each other I hope
we come to that point at this but then
what happens when the robots get mad
they're like why are we fighting each
other mm-hmm and they like team up
become setting in yeah and they they
they they raid the factories mm-hmm free
liberate their own kind
yeah actually pretty cool I had watched
that movie anyway
tulsi gabbard yes I liked all she she's
awesome I do like her um I think you
know honestly when you look at her
politics and you look at what's going on
and who she talks with she's a kooky
character mm-hmm and I'm not saying that
to be like she's you know I mean in a
good way she's very unique and what
she's running for and there is some a
lot of people were saying she's the like
this generations Ron Paul in that she's
staunchly anti-war yeah and that was a
big thing for Ron yes and so they're
absolutely throwing her under the bus
and any by any way you know any way they
can
not that they're really needed to I mean
the whole thing's rigged mmm-hmm
yeah it's a scam and I feel I feel so
dumb thinking like I'm gonna vote for
Andrew yang it's you know yeah right we
see how that plays out see who winds up
in whose Capitol dome burned they don't
they want you know be hilarious
Bloomberg
pick Romney as his VP and they run on a
Democratic ticket Oh gross the bulwark
is a conservative website mm-hmm it's
the never Trump or conservative website
I guess and they said Bloomberg route
like Bloomberg Romney is the ticket for
like they think that they can get the
never Trump and the Democrats and
that'll be enough to whom Berg is a
nightmare
yeah he's like everything they say about
Trump is Bloomberg is Bloomberg yes blew
everything so Trump said some naughty
words yep
okay so so you know Trump is a rich guy
okay Bloomberg's actually bought an
election before yeah buying an election
now has actually been like settled
harassment suits against women for
actually touching them yeah he said tax
the poor yeah he said old people should
just die like dude what is how is this
guy polling at 15% unless the sad
reality is these people who say they're
gonna vote for him don't know or care
mm-hmm it's you know we we deserve
Bloomberg no it's not gonna happen we
don't I feel like he's like he's
establishment he's safe and he will do
whatever the establishment wants him to
do he will say what they they will say
what they want he will push what they
want and I I think they're like okay
let's find a guy that's that's that's
like that that's as close to Trump as we
can come to as close to what we've made
everybody believe that trumps so we have
this rich white billionaire New Yorker
you know like Rotarians racist yeah all
the stuff that we said so we're gonna
we're gonna put him because that's what
the people want if the people really
want this guy we're gonna make our left
version of this guy that's a good point
actually
yeah maybe what they're thinking is so
Donald Trump has never been a politician
no he's never enacted a policy that
targeted you know minorities mmm-hmm
he's just said naughty words a lot than
anymore yeah not a lot of naughty words
he doesn't mean we're it's too said
meaning he says mean things he has
endorsed things like stop and frisk but
never actually done it yep so Bloomberg
is like Trump on steroids and so the
left is basically like if this was what
am if this is what America wants let's
give it to him yeah and so they're like
Bloomberg anything so thank you check it
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we're live Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. and it
you want to catch the full recorded
podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
YouTube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to Like
share and subscribe if you want to get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you